(tense electronic music)
- For a year of my life,
I lived in a cabin in
the woods without any
running water, plumbing or electricity.
- I sang opera for five years.
I can sing in Italian, German, and French.
I have six tattoos.
They all have meaning
to me and they remind me
every day of what matters most in life.
- I once swallowed my tongue piercing and
I owned a 9mm gun.
- When I was a kid, I was
a competitive arm wrestler
and spent my Sundays
dirt-biking through the woods.
I have around 15 tattoos.
I've kind of stopped counting
but I really enjoy it
because it's a cool way to commemorate
certain parts of my life
permanently on my body.
- I once went to Spain
for the sole purpose
of being chased by a herd of bulls.
- My senior year of high school,
I was suspended for three days and
banned from my Senior Prom.
- I have seven tattoos
and I like them because
they make me look tough
until I open my mouth.
(tense electronic music)